element uuh
that's unhex IAM 116 is a triumph for
the new 'no mentallity system the way of
trying to bring together these competing
labs who were trying to synthesize the
these elements because the discovery of
uuh was announced simultaneously by
russian lab in Dubna and the Lawrence
Livermore Lab in the United States
showing that at last
collaboration had come together and
scientists of all countries were working
together to try and understand the
chemistry of these elements what exactly
the chemistry of uuh is is still unclear
but again using Mendeleev's ideas we can
see that this is going to be in the same
group as oxygen sulphur tellurium
polonium and so uuh will be rather more
reactive than or radioactive than
polonium but will have a similar sort of
chemistry